The number is 357.
The figure 3 is in the order of the hundreds.
So it presents 3 hundreds:
1 hundred, 2 hundred, 3 hundred.
3 hundreds here,
they are represented by this 3,
because it is in the order of the hundreds.
Let me write this. These are the hundreds.
Then we have 5 in the order of the decimal.
So it presents 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 tens.
5 tenths.
Finally, we have ...
In the order of the units we have 7.
So it presents 7 units:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, seven units.
Now we want to get 251,
or we want to get 2 hundred,
5 tenths and 1 unit.
Now stop the video and think
how much it will get.
Let us decide together.
Let's first look at the units.
We start with these 7 units
in 3 hundred, 5 tens and 7 units.
357. Seven units.
And we'll get out
1 unit right here.
Let her color it in a different color.
So we'll get 1 unit.
We scratch 1 unit.
And then we will have 6 units.
Now look at the dozens.
We start with 5 tens,
but we will pull out,
we'll pull out five tenths.
So to cross 1 dozen, 2 decades,
3 tens, 4 tens, 5 tens.
We scratched all the tens.
So now we have 0 tenths.
We started with 3 hundred,
but we want to get 2 of them.
We want to get 2 of the hundreds.
Let's do it, let's scratch
1 hundred and 2 hundred.
And we will only remain
this hundred right here.
We'll have 1 hundred.
3 hundreds minus 2 hundreds
is equal to 1 hundred.
I hope you understand now that,
what happens depends on the order.
You can just say, "Oh, I'll align the numbers,
I will look at the places in the different rows.
So here I have 7 minus 1 is 6,
5 minus 5 is 0,
3 minus 2 is 1. "
But I want you to really understand what's going on.
This is 7 units minus 1 unit,
and is equal to 6 units;
this is 5 tenths minus 5 tens,
there will be no tenths, there are 0 tenths,
and 3 hundreds, 3 groups of 100
minus 2 groups of 100 will remain us
only 1 group of 100.
So we'll get 106:
1 hundred, 0 tenths and 6 units.